سبايدر مان يفاجئ المنتخب الامريكي في قطر
[موسيقى]
ايران يرفض ترديد النشيد الوطني فيفا يمنع
رسميا ارتداء شارات
تتابعونها من العربيه رياضه
[موسيقى]
مع رئيس الولايات المتحده
الهاتفيه مع المنتخب الاول المتواجد في
قطر
الى حافه لاعبي المنتخب الامريكي على
مفاجاه جميع المشاركين في كاس العالم وجاء
اساء التجمع الفريق وقبل افتتاح مشواره في
المونديال الذي اتم عامه الثمانيه قدم
كلمات التشجيع للمجموعه ومسحهم قائلا ايها
المدرب الضاني في التشكيله فانا جاهزه
للاعب
ونبقى مع المونديال حيث رافض لاعب المنتخب
الايراني ترديد النشيد الوطني قبل
مباراتهم امام انجلترا في اشاره دعم
للاحتجاجات في بلادهم وصمطه كل عناصر
التشكيله الاساسيه لايران المكونه من 11
لاعبه اثناء عزف النشيد الوطني في استاد
خليفه الدولي وفقا لوكالات الانباء فيما
حاجب التلفزيون الايراني الصور اللاعبين
خلال البث الحي لعزف النشيد الوطني في
المباراه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت سبعه اتحداث اوروبيه في بيان مشترك
ان قاده منتخباتها تخلوا عن ارتداء شارات
المثليين في المونديال وبحسب الانباء
المشهوره فان اعلان المنتخب
بلجيكا ويلز الدنمارك فرنسا والمانيا جاء
بعد ما وجه الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
تهديدا بمنح انذار لاي لاعب يضعوا شاران
متعدده الالوان التي يتم تقديمها
باعتبارها تدعم التنوع والشكر
اجواء كاس العالم وصلت الى الهند صراع
المنتخبات المنافسه وتحديدا بين البرازيل
والارجنتين بدا مبكرا حيث ظهر مقطع فيديو
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في منطقه
كولا الهنديه يظهر اشتباكات بين جماهير
المنتخبين تطور الامر لمعركه متبادله
بالعصي دفعت الشرطه الهنديه لتسجيل
الحادثه والتحقيق فيها
[موسيقى]